we have breaking news on the deadly
serial bombings in Texas police say the
suspected bomber is dead after blowing
himself up inside his vehicle in a
showdown with police this morning the
dramatic events ended nearly three weeks
of terror in the Texas capital the
confrontation happened during a pursuit
on i-35 and Round Rock that's north of
Austin the blasts went off as a SWAT
team members were closing in one officer
was hurt in the explosion
another officer fired at the suspect the
first of five bombings happened on March
2nd just yesterday a package exploded at
a FedEx facility about an hour from
Austin a sixth unexploded package was
found at another FedEx facility police
warned more bombs could still be found
Omar Villafranca is in Round Rock Texas
with how events unfolded overnight Omar
good morning good morning CBS News is
able to confirm that the dead suspect is
23-year old Mark Anthony Condon we can
also tell you in the last 24 to 36 hours
Austin Police started getting tips about
a possible suspect and that led them
right here across the street to this Red
Roof Inn which is right across i-35 in
Round Rock just north of Austin while
officers spotted his car in the parking
lot and that's when they moved in
because he started driving away they
were able to confront him and that's
when the bomb in his car blew up this is
the culmination of three very long weeks
for our community the suspected Austin
serial bombers reign of terror all came
to an end early this morning as members
of the Austin Police Department SWAT
team approached the vehicle the suspect
detonated a bomb inside the vehicle
our CBS affiliate in Austin obtained
these surveillance photos it's believed
he dropped off two suspicious packages
at a South Austin FedEx office earlier
Tuesday investigators found those
packages containing explosives at two
separate FedEx facilities near Austin
and San Antonio one package detonated it
was addressed to a home in Austin one
person was hospitalized the other
package was recovered intact Tuesday
evening a massive police force responded
to another
reported explosion we're going to be
attempting to move people away from the
building but it turned out to be a false
alarm an employee at a Goodwill store
was burned by a flare as he sorted
through a box of donations the bombings
left the city on edge since they began
on March 2nd all the bombings except the
latest at the FedEx facility north of
San Antonio were within Austin City
Limits 39 year-old Anthony house was
killed in the March second bombing 17
year old Raylan Mason was killed on
March 12th when a package bomb exploded
in his kitchen for the families in our
community who lost loved ones or who had
loved ones seriously hurt in these
incidents our heart remains with you
police are saying the threat here is not
over and they're warning people to
please remain vigilant so Omar the
suspect is dead and as you just said
police are concerned what are they what
are they worried about now well at this
point they don't know if this person was
working alone so they don't know if
there's another suspect that they need
to be looking for and the other thing is
they don't know where this person was in
the last 24 hours so they're not sure if
he went to other package delivery places
other FedEx offices and put those
package bombs into the system so they
don't know if those bombs are floating
out there they're being very vigilant
they're still telling people if you see
a suspicious package that you weren't
expecting call us and let us know matter
of fact the shirt's facility just south
of here they're still investigating to
see if there's any more suspicious
devices in there okay I understand that
you know during the investigation they
never looked never released any details
about the packaging how come well they
wanted to keep that close to the vest to
kind of protect the integrity of the
investigation but also they didn't want
the bomber to change his methods but as
we saw the methods we're changing it was
first package bombs that they were
delivering then tripwire and then it
turned into mailing him through FedEx
but that's a big issue that they're
dealing with but they also wanted to
protect some of the people's names that
were on there they knew who they were
they just wanted to make sure that those
people were gonna be okay Omar
Villafranca for us thanks so much Homer